all right let's go with the copycat land
symmetrical variation of the English and
I'm not going to deviate just yet okay
now i could just clamp down on that d
foursquare and let's get there right now
white was may be ready to get it in so I
think um I don't know about this setup
this arrangement right here for white
maybe this night is better placed on
this Square and white would do better to
have the bishop feeing keto hmm no no
because this F pond needs to contribute
i'm pretty sure in some way let's go
here for starters i might think about
pinning that night which is going to be
helpful for maintaining control of these
dark squares this one in particular
three guys are already focused on it and
is it necessary to do this right now
that's well I could play here and just
take him out and then do like a little
night dance if you catch that this is
the dance eventually f68 c7 e6 and then
finally he arrives that d 4 square or
should i just play this I'm torn between
Bishop g4 Knight f6 not sure which is
best and I don't know if I'll be able to
figure it out right now let's see i have
69 f6 there could be a ch3 and then i am
not really going to have a great spot
for my bishop so maybe i should get this
in while i have the opportunity to get
in sometimes I've seen a move like night
here just welcoming this exchange in the
case of Bishop takes the night
recaptures and you know there's not that
imbalance of bishop for night exchange
the night will still be hanging around
to watch out for that D foursquare what
else
okay let's uh is there any rush for
taking this night I'm gonna take them
just get rid of that guy voluntarily
without being provoked because if I were
to let's say play to f6 there is night
g5 and then there's tension between the
bishops if i take the I'm helping the
Queen develop and the other thing is
that the night by being on g5 is just
preparing to free up the F pawns advance
I could play night here but I'm not
going to if the Pawn is going to push
I'll be quite all right without because
was that going to translate into I'll
end up getting that dark square Bishop
okay night right here opposite color
Bishop bending this couldn't enter real
soon Knight takes pawn takes Knight here
chop-chop and that's exactly what we
have no what mmm
let's see
Knight takes Knight pawn takes Knight d4
Oh what is the scoop should I avoid the
night exchange in that kick it away
might want to do that I might not want
to what I do all night here take I don't
like just the opposite color bishop
breathing i don't know that i really get
anything fantastic so i'm not going to
do it now I better come here i was
thinking of here and then here in here
but if i'm going to be kicking the night
away i have to play to e6 let me do that
right now if Bishop here that's not good
because I just have pawn push and then
two minor pieces are hit what else
okay well I think here right now and
well getting ready to hit that or crush
the shatter the kingside structure so
something needs to be done with that and
what else hmm
oh I don't know okay minute 27 something
needs as I went done with the bishop I I
wouldn't be surprised if Bishop here is
maybe a best move just sort of boxing
out the night there is a disconnect and
this can't be correct there's no way
that that could be correct so I'm going
to take care with the check first and
now play here this is very inconvenient
to have to meet for and the queen is
constrained so if the Queen think she
could defend f3 she's mistaken because
she would be overworked overloaded
needing to watch both pond and Bishop
there's no time to resolve this tension
there's no time for in between stuff
night takes here is soon to be lights
out I think it's the King that's needed
to play there and now what next take the
bishop or yeah no no no no no just take
that [ __ ] up and then take here now I
don't like that either let me just come
right out Bishop here could be played in
my queen only has one safe square but i
think i could eventually do what okay
let me just take here I'm not seeing any
in between moves and I'm looking to
maybe get my night on this f5 square
okay interesting well I better go a bit
quicker 53 or maybe I should have tried
to attack this pond I'm oh is that
working that can't be working this is
giving the night a good square and all
the Ponca push though yeah that pond can
push okay so you'll notice that since
this weakness has occurred there's
places that my pieces could be sitting
on the H file the G file Knight f6 to h5
hmm h2 there's under or excuse me h3 is
an only move that's that's a big problem
isn't it where am I um I'm running the
risk of getting in trouble if i take if
i take here with checking here is the
only move Queen back otherwise I'm in
trouble I'm scared there's probably
something better but I didn't want to
have to calculate working myself into a
pin okay let's go here night night right
here is probably good maybe get this
rook involved a little bit this is a
little bit scary yeah that's that's
actually a little bit scary right there
okay now I'll go here everything gonna
be okay can I get this pond whoa let's
trade Queens let's trade Queens just
move quick come on you could do it you
could do it and then the rook is gonna
have to defend the pond I'm pretty sure
at age 62 f 5 just ready to take care
spawn needs to be defended this night
could play here and be hitting both of
my pawns that could be a problem let's
do this or no no no I should have played
here first because that pond was a
weakness I could have been attacking it
now night here is good this is an
excellent move night right here it's a
very good move night trade this helps
out my pawn structure a real ly and what
I would like in this rook and pawn end
game is to get my king to f5 that's the
plan get that rope to f5 or excuse me
the King to f5 I want to basically just
put pressure in King he runs into me
pretty sure this is leading to mate now
an unavoidable mate
there's no way out the King got a little
bit too too close to my op ons and was
running out of squares right there um
good game let's back up because I should
not have I should not have had that
let's see let's see how it could take
something away from this let's flip that
board um I wasn't able to really
capitalize on that a structure I mean
maybe they were there felt like there
should have been something once I took
that bishop but yeah I don't know and
right here another thing is you want to
maybe be a bit careful about efore
because I will be able to get control
over that D foursquare pretty quick you
know so after efore g6 I'd have three
Bishop g7 d3 yeah I mean because i don't
know maybe you could switch up the move
order that's one thing to look for like
if you really wanting to get in d4 maybe
you can consider Knight f3 right now and
after g6 you can get d4 in and then
later follow up with efore so keep that
in mind if you switch there's there's a
significant a significant difference in
other words behind or between Knight f3
and e4 right here that's one point if
you really want to get in d4 instead of
going with the the team or d3 and well
yeah you can't a lot i'm pretty sure
okay i didn't take advantage of you
can't allow the knight takes Bishop I
don't think so i think retreating that
bishop is going to be better and I mean
you defend it well the night coming back
to defend these weak points and I was a
little bit scared here to take this pond
let me let me think twice about this one
let's see Queen takes pawn king f3 my
queen is ready to be trapped
and my night has pressure on it I don't
know it just got really scary with this
rook h1 idea I wasn't I wasn't seeing
him seen it all the way through so I was
a bit scared so you defended well with
the weaknesses you had on your King side
in this position right here after the
Queen's are off how about this move
right here and okay chasing the night is
fine but right here okay you challenge
this right here don't take my night
don't do it night right here on e4
you're hitting both my pawns and you're
eyeing this support point on f6 which is
uh just very important because if my
rooks get let's say too excited to go
after your pawns over here something
there's the possibility for you having a
knight on f6 and should you get a rook
on my back rank and knight on f6 is
allowing for up to g8 move which would
turn out to be made I know it wouldn't
be it would be made but I would be
having to I guess you could say at least
perpetual going back and forth on these
two squares but it's definitely a bit
scary for my king to have this support
point available for your own night so
night right here do not do not trade
nights this is helping out my king
position when you look at it my king
would love to be up towards the center
and now you give me that possibility so
avoid that night exchange is my
suggestion at this end game stage and I
think you're just winning out your
wedding one of my pawns by force and
this is going to be a very important
lunch for me to hang on to because I
don't have him then your sepan is ready
to roll